I want to name a few guys and I want you
to tell me what you learned about
yourself through guarding them okay okay
yeah you can tell me you learn about
yourself or you learn about them and how
it helped you okay cool let's do it the
one that I saw first was Paul George so
I'll start with PG cool um
PG
just
like obviously how skilled he is that's
just like number one you know but just
the body movement with the ball like how
he moves and
also that's one guy like he you got to
guard him close because you can shoot
you can't go under because he's gonna
shoot the three and like so you got to
be aggressive but he's one of those guys
where I learned like you can't be too
aggressive because then he's gonna get
the foul call so you know what I'm
saying so that's why I really learned
like all right like I gotta be solid
like you can't really reach you can't
really like you know some guys get
really aggressive like uh like some guys
really like like Dylan Brooks was
example like you know but I think he's
he's kind of okay cuz that's like his
who he is so the ref's kind of let it go
you know it's a little you know it's a
little it's a little different sometimes
so he could play a little bit more with
his chest and be aggressive but you know
sometimes guys like me like ref see me
like bump a guy I'm like I don't even we
that much whistle exactly so PG was one
of those guys where you have to be super
solid and
like make him make tough
shots and and I kind of took from that
offensively
going a guy like that knowing like
okay any slight mess up any little
hiccup I did on him defensively he's
he's gonna like he knows when to get a
foul like he just knows so anytime I
kind of put a hand out there or whatever
it's a foul so now it's like it just
goes in my back of my head how many
times I guard I'm like now I'm on
offense and I'm coming I'm I'm being
aggressive and once I kind of feel that
contact it's like I'm going to get foul
you know so learning from guys like that
from guarding
yeah and so that's so I'll take that
from him I love I love that answer
because PG so incorrectly gets like the
the reputation PG has is not the
reputation PG should have because PG has
no flaw in his
game not at all he does not have a flaw
in his game and people have let all this
other stuff Cloud that fact I cannot
imagine what it is like out there having
a g PG so I because do you great like he
there's nothing wrong with how he plays
basketball not one thing he can shoot he
could dribble he can finish he can jump
he could pass you can playmake like play
defense I know you're got a little older
so maybe defense is going down a little
bit but like you know in this years ago
you know body and stuff like he guard so
he just does everything out there okay
what about Luca oh God so him that's
a that he's more like
a
same thing like Fallon wise don't don't
even dare don't even dare he's too smart
don't even don't even don't even he's
gonna he's he's going to he's going he's
going to he's goingon to find that call
I think just
pace and it's it's you can say it all
you want it's like teaching people like
you know learning with Pace but some
sometimes you have it or you don't and
like just his body how he's built like
he he can play that like some guys can't
play that pace so like you know what I'm
saying like he's strong and like wide so
like he could hold you off like if
you're small skinny and like he can't
really do that too much because a guy
can just get right back but just how he
plays I think like the misdirection like
just kind of like setting you up to like
make a move real quick like he'll come
back slow kind of relax and he come at
you real fast like he's like CU he's not
slow like he's slow like maybe like when
he's moving but he plays slow his gears
like he got really good Gears of like
going fast going slow to fast and back
to slow to fast again so like guarding
that it's like you gotta you gotta be
locked in at all times and try to make
him make tough shots but same thing
offensively with that like you just you
could kind of learn with a like kind of
pace with him as well yeah like he's
slow but by choice exactly like he and
he's and it's good for him because he
could play slow and like he's just
setting you up and then he's going to go
fast then like soon as you take a step
he's just might step back like you know
like it's crazy how much separation off
a step back how slow he's going cuz he
he'll go and then pop real quick and
then he just separates it's it's it's
ridiculous I love it okay two more uh
well come to the east Jason Tatum Tatum
um
like honestly I
think as many great things that he
does
like I think what I take away from is
probably his finishing I think he
finishes really well like he's crafty
like he like he you see some of his
finishes he does like he's he's real
crafty like sometimes like you might be
able personally like you play basketball
your whole life and you might have like
a easy like layup like you might take a
step a little too far and go reach for
layup he's kind of smart where like
he'll make all these dribble moves and
get to the rim and then take like one
more dribble where he's already kind of
there so it missed it makes the the
timing for the guy that's getting back
to go block or the weak side like he'll
he'll move move move and then get there
so now you think he's about to take off
cuz he's like he's 69ine like you think
he's about to go lay the ball up or dunk
it then he just like takes like kind of
like one more dribble so he gives
himself two more steps and then he just
like so that but I see you playing it in
your head exactly exactly I think for
him just just uh even offensively just
his game like setting things up like
setting the pick and roll up up like he
it's like he dribble dribbles and
then counters like he's real good at
counters too like he you think he's
about to come that way then he might
snatch back and then come back like so
I'll say it's finishing for sure but
guarding
him he's one of those guys just
personally for me like kind of with the
PG and and Luca too you just got to be
like those guys you gota be solid yeah
and you kind of got to study like those
are guys like you got to study like if
you just go out there just just naked
and and not know what they're about to
do all the moves they got you're going
to you're going to bite on a couple of
them and as it's over for you so and his
in and out I think his in and- out game
his In-N-Out is is nasty so yeah that's
that's that's what I take from it I love
this I feel like I'm liking film study
okay so for the final one I'll let you
pick out of these three maybe which one
you feel like you learn the most from
yeah um Steph LeBron KD pick
one
man
I'll probably I'll probably I'll
probably go with
Steph because he's very he's very
unique because it's like he's the only
guy one of only
guys where you guard he bring it up and
you got he come off all these screens
and you kind of low key feel
that you're already locked in
defensively looking now about to talk
about something you're so locked in
defensively on the ball no matter what
like just at all times like you're guard
you guard any Superstar especially step
like you're you're locked in like he got
the ball you're like zoned in you're
locked in like I'm here you know some
screens don't go if you don't screen be
ready him to Pat Pat Micha go behind the
back step back you got to be just very
for him to shoot at at any
time it's just like that
just guard him off ball it's because
like you just guard even so many
Superstar guys like them off ball is
kind of like they relax like they're
kind of they do all these moves and
stuff they play they're kind of like all
right I'll let the other guy go so
they're kind of if they're off ball like
they're they're really much a little bit
chilling a little bit but I think that
makes them just so much more lethal is
because you're used to just like all
right like I just guarded this dude for
10 12 seconds up on top of the key he
didn't get a shot off like thank God
like he didn't make so he passed the
ball go away that second
you and you like look to see like what's
happening on the other side of Court you
look back he is gone like he is gone and
everybody on his team knows it so it's
like you turn and you lose them you're
starting to chase them and everybody
setting their angles where you can't go
over or like if you go under like
they're flipping it so they're they're
just he's just non-stop so yeah he's the
most unique with like you will it's
easier to play on ball with him because
like as a Defender like as anybody else
like it's it's easier to relax off ball
than on ball you know cuz on ball you're
right here like you see it so you have
to be engaged off ball you can relax so
once you relax he's gone so yeah that's
what makes him so difficult
and and I think about Stu that I I take
away from
him is like personally is he's big
hockey assist guy which I appreciate
about him
like how much coverage he gets with
double team stuff he just makes the
right play you know what I'm saying
sometimes he might get crazy cuz like he
he plays he plays fun so like he might
try some crazy sometimes but that's
just natural yeah but majority of the
time like he hit the roller or hit the
next guy and they'll make the play
because he brings two to the ball so
take that for him just like making a
simple play and I feel like
even I think in the playoffs last year I
think my coaches and stuff and everybody
was talking about like be prepared for
maybe them blitzing and stuff like that
and I'm like looking at I'm like okay
like that should be an advantage for us
like I'm not going to be crazy to hold
it and like get the hell out the way
like on no like I'll make the simple
read and then it's four and three
another end so that's why I take away
from him but guarding that man it's just
like it's that's like a 24 shot clock
like you just got to be at all times be
be prepared because once you get off the
ball it makes him even more lethal
something you said that's interesting is
how you know he relaxes I feel like that
is so intentional by him yeah do do you
agree like he he understands that it
might be taken as though he's chilling
in that moment and and he's G you just
throw it and cut he just little his
little head W his body language cut
through like ah like all right like damn
they they got me my got me like I have
the back cut layup like they play good
defense cool and like you you like deny
it like at The Rim you like nobody threw
it over then you like turn to go look
cuz the ball's probably in the post and
you kind of like then you just like look
at the posty was about to happen and you
just look back to wherever he just came
from and from he's supposed to be in a
corner supposed to be but then you like
look and his ass is like kind of in a
slot in the wing you're like how the
hell and then like the ball's like
getting skipped you're just you just
praying don't go because you know you
look over at the bench and the coach is
just staring at you like bro I'm like
totally like damn my fault yeah it's
like you can no nights off when you are
when you are facing
it